hello everyone and welcome back to the
1909 match between Jose raúl capablanca
and Frank James Marshall this is Game
seven and even though we've already
reached game thirteen I said that we
will go back to Game seven at one point
so this is at that point capablanca is
currently leading the match seven to one
is first to eight wins the draw don't
count and once again Marshall has the
white pieces and it's really one of the
better achievements Marshall got in this
in this match they played so without
further ado I really do hope you're
having an excellent Saturday now let us
enjoy this game
Marshall opens with d4 as he often does
in this match we have d5 c4 e6 we have
Knight to c3 in the knight to f6 the
Queens gambit declined is on the board
and we have the line that two of them
have been playing this match for the
entire time
III and not knife 3/4 cup of Blanco goes
once again for the last curve variation
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
Bishop to d3 again we've seen later that
in games or in game 11 and onward C
captures on d5 has been adopted by
Marshall in this match but now Knight
captures on c3 be captures on c3 and now
Capablanca doesn't go for D captures on
c4 and b6 like he did previously now he
goes for Bishop to d7 perhaps he thinks
Marshall perhaps found a different ideas
against this so he changes lines Knight
to f3
we have castles by capablanca and now C
captures on d5 finally by Marshall he
captures on d5 and now Queen to b3
pressuring the d5 pawn and also
preventing the light square bishop from
being developed in the future as
currently only the bishop is defending
the b7 point knife to have six the night
from f6 now defense the d5 pawn we have
a four by Marshall and not c5 capablanca
doesn't have to bother himself with the
c6 move so immediately going for that
Center again comes up with a threat of
playing c4 and here Queen to a 3 here
Queen to a3 does work because there is
no rook on a4 to be attacked by Bishop
to d7 like we've already seen now the
pawn is pinned the Queen
seven is undefended and it's Capablanca
with v6 strengthening in the center
perhaps the light square bishop will be
developed this way a five attacking the
v6 pawn wanting to open up the a file
and the brush up to b7 very nice
Marshall finally castles and here we
have Queen to c7 we have rook F to be
one and here Capablanca said that he
already felt that Marshall was a lot
better he transferred all of the plate
to the Queen side and it's very hard for
a couple Blanca to make a move and here
later after the game could belong I said
that he should have played rook F to be
eight and here he might you know muster
up some sort of a defense but he played
nice to d7 and the move Marshall played
here is something kappa blanka didn't
even take into consideration the knight
now serves as additional protection to
the c5 pawn to d6 pawn and Marshall
plays a move that's an excellent move
cover blanc I never even thought about
this move so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the move
Capablanca missed in this game for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just found a
move capablanca missed I mean that's
that's a success in itself and for those
who just won't enjoy it show Bishop to
f5 attacking the the defender so what's
the problem here
with this position the problem is and
the core of the problem is that the
Queen on c7 is undefended which you'll
see you know in a few seconds so what is
what can black play now obviously you
want to keep you know it'd be best if
you could just close up the entire Queen
side so this rooks and Queen don't
really do anything on the Queen side but
it's very hard to do this you can't
really trade down if you play something
like C captures on d4 you get C captures
and now again you're either facing the
same problem let's say well Bishop to c6
you get roofed see one simply pinning
the bishop here and after rook a to c8
you would get a capture Sun b6 a capture
some b6 and now Queen to b3 and again
black is black is really struggling to
find a move here if you try and trade on
some more let's say
Ruka eight didn't you get Queen C Queen
c2 attacking the h7 pawn
twice and also a double attack against
the bishop on c6 so not much you can do
here rope captures you it really
captures now you have freed yourself and
therefore h6 trying to get rid of all
the threats you get Bishop captures on
the Sun and now you have the problem
that Bishop cannot capture because the
Queen and c7 is undefended and if Queen
captures ninety five attacks the Queen
and the bishop so this 95 is a problem
in a lot of variations now after this
Bishop captures the knight here on the
other hand if you play something like c4
trying to close down the center saying
okay I'm just gonna close it up after a
capture some b6 I don't really care if
white plays this then you face Queen to
e7 we've already said the night is now
attacked twice and you can't move the
knight because the Queen and c7 is
unguarded and after rook a to d8
defending again you get this very nice
nicely if I move then I still can't
capture the Queen and c7 is unguarded
and after Bishop to c8 giving more
defense here and now you get a capture
Sun b6 now a capture some v6 and now
rook to e8 attacking the defender of the
d7 night and here after black makes a
move you don't really have a useful move
you have to play something h6 now you
get capture some b7 Bishop captures on
d7 look after sandy eight and now you
have to decide either you will capture
with the Queen and then you will lose a
piece or you will capture with the rook
and then rook the Queen captures and if
seven comes King moves Queen e7 knight
of seven is a threat you can't move the
rook because of Queen capture Sun d7 and
if you play something I just move the
King than white people simply bring his
rook into the game and will very quickly
win this game and black is for the rest
of the game pretty much without a move
so yeah after this Bishop to a5 move by
marshal capablanca decided to go rook F
the c8 bringing a defender to the Queen
and c8 and we have Bishop captures on d7
Queen captures on d7 and now a6 first
this is one other problem now you have
to play Bishop to c6 and the rook is no
longer defending the c5 pawn
so you lose a pawn but at least you've
defended the position worship see six we
have D captures B captors and Queen
captures on c5 so Marshall is here up
upon perhaps perhaps even for the first
time in the match
look eight to be eight my cup of lanka
it's very hard to develop the rooks
because you constantly have to keep an
eye on this nice to e5 move which would
come as a wouldn't attack against the
Queen but also against the bishop here
and as the bishop is already attacked
once this rook can never leave this
square so it's odd that capablanca plays
this rook a to b8 move he thought that
tactics work in his favor but this one
particular time the tactics actually
worked in Marshall Marshalls favor
Marshall played rook captures on b8 we
have root capture sin b8 and here Knight
to e5 it seems that cup of lanka
blundered the piece but capablanca had
everything prepared here he simply plays
Queen to a5 which makes sense now if you
capture the piece you get Queen b1 check
rogue captures and rope capture Sun be
one will be checkmate
but a Marshall after Queen a5 simply
played f4 he defends the knight and also
makes an escape route for the King for
king king of - King g3 if needed here we
have a problem that now you still have
to defend your Bishop your Bishop is
under attack twice if you just move the
bishop Queen captures an a7 creates a
powerful passed pawn and after you move
the rook as your rook is under attack
now Queen moves let's say you just go
back for Queen d7 offer Queen trade and
now you have a pest the pawn that's
already on a6 coming to a7 it will be a
winning position for marshal
so after f4 we have looked to be six
kappa blanka blocks the Queen's attack
towards the a7 pawn and also the rook is
guarding the bishop here but while it
does defend against these two threats it
allows marshal to create another one so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find a move marshal played after
which Capablanca resigned the game I
will give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you really know how to
have a nice Saturday and for those who
just want to enjoy the show the movies
Queen captures on b6 after marshal
played this josé raúl capablanca
resigned the game sir a wonderful game
again by Marshall 25 moves beating josé
raúl capablanca oh this definitely
counts counts as a miniature and this
will be the only game in the match
Marshall wins why did you resign well
now if you capture the Queen then you
get Knight captures here and that there
is no way to prevent this spawn from
queening if you lo queen e6 we have
simply a7 Queen captures eight eaters
rook or Queen rook captures Queen
captures and rook captures will be
checkmate but none of the other ideas
work so now after this the screen
capture Sun v6 was planed cover Blanc a
simple design so a very nice victory for
Marshall at least you know he didn't
lose the match eight to zero but yeah I
like we said now we go into the part of
the match after this is a game seven but
we've already seen even game thirteen
and now as I've already mentioned
capablanca is leading 7 to 1 but the
match lasted for 23 games so how did
this happen if already on after game 12
cup Blanc is leading 7 to 1 we'll find
out in the next video in this series
which will be the final game game 23 of
the match marshall vs Capablanca and
then we are going to discuss a bit more
about this match and what controversy
there was to it
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it
I would like to thank Chang Dean Proctor
my knee bone ostrich Giacomo de la marca
and lonliness polities for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with the final game of the
match as mentioned and we are also
starting up the Tata Steel series thank
you all and I will see you soon